elle s'appelle louise bourgeois elle est
française et américaine elle à 95 ans
aujourd'hui elle est considérée comme
l'une des plus grandes artistes
d'avant-garde du siècle dernier ses
sculptures ses installations ont souvent
choqué ou scandalisé aujourd'hui ce sont
des références la tate modern de londres
lui consacre une grande rétrospective
maryse burgot dominique marault tel sur
place à quelques mètres de la cathédrale
saint-paul une créature menaçante pour
le commun des mortels c'est une araignée
géante pour l'auteur de cette oeuvre
c'est une mère aux tentacules
protectrice
derrière cette étonnante sculptures se
cache une frêle silhouette est pourtant
un monstre sacré de l'art contemporain
louise bourgeois 96 en double
nationalité française et américaine
interviewé ici dans cet appartement de
new york qu'elle ne quitte presque plus
j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui c'est
plus la vie qui me contrôler que moi qui
contrôle la vie
après cette grande phrase je peux avoir
un coca cola
louise bourgeois joue volontiers les
vieilles dames indignes la jeune
sculptrice des années 30 a pris avec le
temps des allures de chef indienne mais
son oeuvre inclassable est jugé
aujourd'hui monumentale des sculptures
totem évoquant la fragilité de nos
existences des corps sans tête livrer à
l'hystérie de nos villes des
excroissances dérangeante des sexes
masculins suspendu pour évoquer ce père
que louise bourgeois détestait et ses
araignées pour ne jamais oublier une
mère vénéré mais trop tôt disparu
cette oeuvre avec l'araignée symbolise
la figure de la nar tisseuse
elle protège il nourrit cette cage
secret c'est l'endroit où l'on se sente
en sécurité où l'on peut réfléchir
jeu j'avais perdu quand j'avais 18 ans
et là je suis devenu totalement
totalement perdu
la jeune fille perdue à surmonter
l'absence elle l'a même sublime et au
point d'en faire une oeuvre que se
discute aujourd'hui les plus grands
musées du monde